Rob congratulations on this show I gotta
say first of all I've got a 10 year old
and a 12 year old at home and they're
finally growing out of the stage where
they think everything dad does is
awesome and it's great and I'm getting
into the stage now where they're just
kind of trolling me about pretty much
like every waking moment of my life this
is what I have to expect for the rest of
my life with them I I'd like to give you
a more positive answer unfortunately I I
cannot tell a lie just Buckle in that's
all I can tell you Buckle in
I imagine that creating a series like
this with your son must have been
amazing and also emotional when did you
know that you guys hit on something that
you really wanted to pursue something
that was going to be great well what's
really special about this because look
as an actor and producer you know I'm
always trying to come up with new
projects right and it's very rare
and you always wonder what the audience
is gonna like it or if the audience if
there's even an audience for it this is
one of those rare things where we knew
there was an audience who liked it
beforehand because they loved John Owen
trolling me
on my Instagram account it was a viral
thing and that's what led us to go hey
maybe we should make a show
because people enjoy it so much so we
had that rare opportunity where the
audience was saying more please
and we just had to figure out what the
more was going to be and that took a
while it really did because um
you know how do you bring that tone
to a show what world do you set it in
what are the characters and that's what
eventually led us to unstable
what was the moment for you and I'm sure
there were a few of them probably many
but the moment for you were you almost
couldn't hold back like how proud you
were as a dad in the process of either
filming something with John Owen or
making this with him
there are a bunch of them
um
I think
I I think the
it started on 9-1-1 Lone Star where John
Owen wrote on the staff and he wrote
one of our most successful episodes and
he would he would the writer would come
all the writers would come to the set
and we'd do a scene and afterwards
everybody would huddle up and talk about
the take and how we did it and the first
time Johnny did that
I heard him talking about what he
thought the scene should be and what we
could maybe do better
and I agreed with everything I was like
wow that was really smart and then I it
hit me that that's my kid
because as he was doing it he was a peer
and a smart peer and that has just
continued with with unstable he's a
really smart writer he's a really good
producer he's a really good actor and I
forget he's my kid
um a lot and then I remember he's my kid
and then I get really proud
that's awesome now in in this show you
guys are constantly coming up with new
inventions right that are big inventions
or small inventions that are helping
everyday life put something that you
would love to have invented that would
help your everyday life as an actor ooh
all right well I'd like to I'd like to
come up with a scan where I could scan
the script
and then a port that would go into a
body part
and then I would know the dialogue I
wouldn't have to memorize it
oh that's it so you don't have to go in
there and like try and go through that
whole process it's like what is it chat
GPT nobody has to write anything anymore
I want a version I want a version of
that where nobody has to memorize
anything anymore
by the way you may have get you may have
solved a major plot point for us in in
the next season of of the show this is a
really good idea I'm stealing this
that's it and then now you're gonna be
you know also add inventor to your list
of many many accomplishments that's
right
give me a little bit of credit you could
say I met this guy and he said the thing
I will I will yeah fantastic Rob
congratulations on the show thanks so
much for taking the time thank you
appreciate it